let's talk more broken guns in call of
duty
before we begin thank you to everyone
who watched part one and submitted a
comment or a suggestion for more broken
guns because we're back for part two
baby
this time we won't be highlighting any
of the goofy quirky or barely functional
guns
just the overpowered broken ones so make
sure you watch part 1 first
there were a lot of clunky guns in
2008's world at war while they dealt
high damage their slow aim down sides
time and reload speeds could bring the
game to a crawl
enter the mp40 this popular submachine
gun kept you quick on your feet
had enough bullets to spare and had
higher damage than any gun in his class
at close quarters your enemies didn't
stand a chance
and don't lie you use the stopping power
perk we all did
most of the submachine guns in this game
were pretty good thompson ppsh and even
the type 100
however the king is and always will be
the mp40
you're probably familiar with the fr-556
in warzone and modern warfare
in warzone this thing was one of the
worst guns you could possibly use
even in a fun off-meta build you'd lose
to just about anyone
so in august of 2020 the fr-5 i'm just
going to call it the famas
got a range buff to make it more
competitive in warzone however
this buff also accidentally worked on
the 12 gauge deputy
underbarrel shotgun stupid name aside
this attachment became one of the most
destructive things in the entire game
it was a two-shot kill one for the armor
and the other to eliminate
oh my god no no this gun made me take a
week off of war zone and question my
life choices
but before you know it it was quickly
patched and we went back to not using it
let's move on to black ops 2 and its
legendary sniper rifles
just about all of them were a one shot
kill to anywhere on the body
i'm not much of a sniper myself and i
definitely didn't snipe when this game
came out
but boy i wish i did it's no wonder
every time i saw one of these bad boys
it was decked out in diamond camo
just listen to this how many times do
you remember hearing that right before
you got laid out
back in the day i wish someone told me
how easy this was by the way this
footage you're watching was captured
this week
so these guns are still busted i'm
telling you even if you're not a sniper
fan
you don't know the word broken until
you've used one of these
loved by many the mp7 in modern warfare
3 was a little
terror i booted up the game and my
memories with the gun came
flooding back this thing was the moab
machine the pocket acr
the close quarters king its biggest
strengths were its low
predictable recoil and its super fast
fire rate
on paper it wasn't the strongest
submachine gun but its handling made it
feel like an assault rifle
if you were in close range of an enemy
the mp7 did all the heavy lifting and
lasered them off the map
it also had plenty of ammo to spare with
its stock 40 round magazine
this gun feels too good to be true
infinity ward could have easily added
recoil or nerfed the magazine size to
half
but they didn't and now the mp7 remains
in the broken gun hall of fame
i love it you love it let's move on
right after this
double
most semi-auto rifles and call of duty
are pretty unremarkable
however the fal osw from black ops 2 was
memorable for how destructive it was
as a base weapon it was a solid 2-3 shot
kill with super low recoil
but when you reached level 10 you
unlocked the select fire attachment that
made this thing full
auto when paired with the grip this
thing became the broken mess you
probably remembered
of course word got out and treyarch
patched this monstrosity by adding
recoil to the select fire when it was
attached
although some people say the extra kick
helped them get more headshots so
when the first black ops game launched
in 2010 we were given the broken ass
famas
it was an early unlockable gun that got
plenty of attention for its high fire
rate and low recoil
i personally prefer the galil but i
think it's because my memories with the
famas were post patch
that's right this thing got nerfed with
the 1.1 update that shook up the recoil
slowed down the aim down sights time and
widen the bullet spread of its hip fire
this gun is still fun today but it's a
shell of what it once was
long ago
what can i say about the acr we've
talked about it before in our best guns
of call of duty video
where our very own dave jewett kindly
reflects on it as we all do
when you think of the acr you think of
one thing that
recoil or should i say the lack of it
when playing modern warfare 2 back in
2009 this was the first gun i remember
ever being called a laser
it was that legendary steadiness that
popularized it
and even though it wasn't the most
powerful it was a breeze connecting
shots and taking down enemies from just
about any range you can conceive
any attachment you added was simply a
bonus but some fan favorites include the
silencer
and the extended magazine what you're
seeing here is actually footage from
modern warfare 3 where the acr
still kicked ass let's talk about some
of the weapons in call of duty's most
recent title
cold war at the time of recording call
of duty black ops cold war has been out
for less than a month
players were quick to find that the m16
and the og were just
nasty let's put it this way both of them
were nerfed after the game's launch week
they each had their damage ranges
dropped burst delays increased
and reduced effectiveness of the laser
attachment
and you know what they're still good i
played around with the og here and did
so well that my next lobby was filled
with some pretty tough customers
i got work and got a notification saying
to erase the game from my hard drive and
just try again next year
and while i'm here i might as well
mention call of duty 4's m16
this thing was one of the grandfathers
of broken weapons i
love the young people
most shotguns and call of duty are solid
when used correctly
close quarters small maps you know the
deal but what if one of your shotguns
was also a sniper rifle
enter the 725 from modern warfare the
range was filthy
but to be fair i think infinity ward
encouraged players to use the 725 this
way
due to all of its long range attachments
and optional slug ammo
but it was just too much
players were building sniper classes
because modern warfare
and they were going on rampages until
the massive november 8th update
this fixed the aim down sights time
widened its hip fire and of course
reduced that range at the time warzone
wasn't even out yet but you know it
would be the op gun of the week if it
were
ah the mp5 i don't know about you but
when i use this gun i feel like i'm
cheating and that's in both modern
warfare
and cold war like others on this list
the mp5
isn't the strongest weapon in its class
in fact in terms of damage
it's cold war's weakest submachine gun
so why is this thing so good
well it's got low recoil great aim down
sights high fire rate and a slew of
useful attachments that make this thing
incredibly versatile even in a game like
cold war where bullet velocity is a very
real thing
the mp5 hits like a truck and is a
contender for the best submachine gun
for two call of duty titles in a row
when the m16 og and ffar were nerfed
week after launch you bet your ass the
mp5 was too
next up we have a few guns from black
ops 4 beginning with the vmp
i'll be honest i didn't grind black ops
4's multiplayer long enough to see the
vmp return
i remember it from black ops 3 but in
our last video you all said it was
broken
especially in black ops 4. well i
downloaded it and
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys were right this thing is gross
also an honorable mention goes out to
the stingray which a few of you
mentioned in part 1's comments
i never got to unlock it but watching
footage of this thing pre-patch makes me
queasy so i'll take your word for it
the a.s val you already know where i'm
going with this
when this thing launched with season six
it was an unassuming assault rifle that
had a built-in suppressor
it had a fast time to kill a small
magazine size and worked really well at
short range
however at level 42 you unlocked the
9x39 ammo conversion
that broke warzone in half while the
description calls for a higher bullet
penetration
this was able to shoot through any
structure you can think of and not just
a single barrier either
players were wall banging their shots
and using the snapshot grenade to find
anyone and everyone it took zero effort
to rack up kills
and the only thing that could stop you
in the final circle was another player
doing the exact same thing
funny enough the other gun released
alongside the as val was the spr208
which was also busted
both of these guns got their patches but
the impact had been made
these guns were definitely broken
next we have infinite warfare's proteus
in the days of summer event that took
place in june of 2017
we were gifted three free guns and one
of them was the proteus
sniper shotgun hybrid while it sounded
kind of strange it didn't matter because
on launch day this gun was a hot mess
it had a game breaking bug where when
hip fired your shot would land on the
nearest opponent
that's right the proteus had a built-in
aimbot
what's worse is that it was a one-shot
kill the proteus was patched within 24
hours
but as you can see here people had loads
of fun and captured their memories
online for us to enjoy
by the way even after the patch this
thing is still supposedly pretty damn
nasty
did you get your hands on the broken
proteus for the day let me know in the
comments
next up is the fennec but probably not
the one you're thinking of
we're talking call of duty mobile i
booted up the game and gave it a try
and yeah this shouldn't be allowed i
didn't even need to dual wield them to
see what you guys meant
one fennec alone just rips through
everyone this footage is recorded using
the desktop app
but trust me when i say i had the same
experience on my actual phone
[Music]
black ops 3's 205 brecci shotgun
from the comments section of our part 1
video this was by far the most highly
requested gun
we've previously discussed the brecci on
our channel so i figured you guys didn't
want to hear about it
and i was wrong this semi-auto shotgun
killed faster than almost any other
weapon in the game
two shots from the hip was all it took
this gun also fell
victim to the jitter mod this would
glitch your firing animation and spam
your shots faster than you intended
even after that was patched out players
flocked to the brexit for its fast time
to kill and spammy qualities
again on paper it wasn't supposed to be
the best shotgun but here we are still
talking about it
it was so smooth and deadly to the point
of annoyance
you can just pick up your controller and
wail on children who don't obey the esrb
ratings
bottom line people love the brecci and
love to hate it
but i think we can all agree it was
broken
remember if you don't see the broken gun
you were thinking of on this list
check out part one here thanks for
watching and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you